well let's now go back to our breaking
news this hour at the international
criminal court and the Hague has issued
an arrest warrant for Russian President
Vladimir Putin we can now bring in
protea hoffmanski from the Hague he is
the president of the international
criminal court thank you sir for joining
us here on Al Jazeera I have to ask you
to start off with Russia says it does
not recognize the ICC it it signed the
Rome statute never ratified it and Putin
says that he doesn't really care what
does this actually mean for President
Putin
this is Frankly Speaking completely
irrelevant the according to the IC
statute
which has 123 State parties two-thirds
of the whole International Community the
court has jurisdiction on crime
committed in the territory of State
party
or a state which has accepted its
jurisdiction and if Ukraine has accepted
the icc's
twice in 2014 then in 2015 uh 43 states
have referred the situation in Ukraine
and to the court which means that they
have formally triggered our jurisdiction
uh let me stress that the court has a
jurisdiction over crimes committed on by
anyone on the territory of the Ukraine
from November 2013 onwards uh regardless
of of uh of the nationality of the ls
perpetrators so sir just to be clear
then what does this mean for President
Putin if he is traveling outside of
Russia could he then be arrested is
there um I guess a a need to arrest him
by another state that is a signatory
all estate parties have the legal
obligation to cooperate fully with the
court and obviously the obligation to
cooperate covers also the obligation to
arrest a person in respect to which they
are responsibility so there are two
cases that you filed here but there have
obviously been many more allegations of
atrocities should we be expecting more
the situation is obviously still in the
hands of the of the prosecutor so far
there were two requests for the response
and on the basis of this request their
responses will be issued but obviously
it does not mean that it is the end of
the of the of the situation of the cases
uh the the case the cases can be
expanded the new new allegation may be
formulated can be formulated by the
prosecutor
on the basis of collected information
evidence well let me ask you then a
little more about these two cases there
was speculation amongst plenty of
experts and a push potentially for some
of the charges to include genocide at
the moment we're looking at crimes
against humanity can I ask you about the
choice of the language here and the
choice of the charges at stake
talking about the crimes against
humanity according to the decision of
the of the pre-trial chamber they asked
or answers for the alleged war crimes of
deportation of children from Ukrainian
occupied territories to the Russian
restoration
it concerns both of the of the suspects
okay well given that this is also a very
politically sensitive time I want to ask
you about the choice to do this right
now China is obviously trying to break a
piece and seems to be making some
Headway is there a concern that this
might actually prolong the war
this is the political consideration we
are doing our job you know we are the
court of law we are active at the basis
of the request of the prosecutor which
has lead the independent office and we
based on the presented information and
evidence and we do what is expected from
from us to be done but the consequences
including the political consequences of
this step it's uh it's basically
something which is behind our
consideration sure okay so leaving that
aside then let me ask you about the
evidence Gathering here there have been
reports both in Russia and in Ukraine of
the issue of children being being taken
from from across the border are you
getting cooperation from various
different authorities and trying to put
all of that together
this is my understanding but I have to
to tell you that that the content of the
arrest warrants are secret according to
the decision of the chamber and to tell
you true I don't know what is how this
situation look like
but the the chamber specifically
um
allowed us to share the information
about the existence of this this
restaurant about the personal concerns
about the crimes alleged not the more
therefore is nothing more to share well
so I do want to ask you you alluded
there to the political consequences of
this decision and I understand as you
say that the court is doing its job as
president of the ICC when you're faced
with situations like this are you not
personally concerned about how this
might then play out in terms of the
ongoing conflict
so you know it
I I will repeat we are the court of law
but obviously we are fully aware that
that we are not acting in the political
vacuum
but it cannot be the case that we
consider political consequences the
statute is very clearly formulate our
mandate and we just act according to the
mandate to realize the promise of the
wrong statutes included him it's Bramble
well we've been speaking to the
president of the international criminal
court Peter hofmansky speaking to us
live from the Hague thank you so much
sir for sparing us some time right now
um thank you for joining user thank you
thank you very much thank you